hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video today we're on outer worlds and
there's been a lot of talk about outer
worlds of course being one of the
coolest games that a lot of people have
been playing so a lot of people are
hyped about it and first off I just want
to say thank you to private division for
giving me a code early thankfully they
hit me up and they gave me a code to
play a little bit like a couple hours
early to say so thank you to them for
that code but yeah I've made it pretty
far into the game in the hours that I've
been playing and there was a lot of
things that I noticed that I'd wish I
had known ahead of time so that I never
had to you know backtrack or start
getting again because I had screwed it
up during the process so that's really
the whole point of today's video of
course there's not gonna I'm gonna try
to keep these spoilers to a minimum I'm
not going to be talking about much
really just a unique weapon that you can
get within like the first 30 minutes of
the game and then like the first planet
that you ever actually get to in the
game of nothing of the other sort and
I'm not gonna be showing any key
characters and such so if you do want to
continue there really isn't a spoiler
warning but there also is if you do if
you don't want to hear a single thing
about it
just laws like to be if you do enjoy
guys subscribe for new now let's get
started so number one on the list is
gonna be about breaking down items
you're gonna get to a point in the game
where you find loads of items some might
be duplicates so might be unique weapons
you've never seen before like some laser
sword or an LMG or grenade launcher they
maybe haven't seen in your game yet but
aren't really your forte maybe you're
not big on the big weapons and want to
go a little bit sneaky I totally
understand so instead of selling those
if the price is too low or maybe not
gonna fit your bill with how much money
you're gonna be getting
you can choose to break down those items
for parts simply go to your inventory
and hover over a weapon and click Q if
you are on PC or whatever it happens to
be on console and then break down the
item this is going to give you weapon
parts and if you break down armor these
are going to give you armor parts these
are going to be super helpful for
repairing items at a workbench some of
the NPC's within the game can actually
give repairs and stuff for you as I've
heard but they do charge a bit of a
hefty fine so why not just do it
yourself at the oil at your own place
for a very small fee of just weapon
parts you could of course use the mods
as well to make your weapons as tip-top
shape as possible so definitely keep
this in mind for number two it's
definitely gonna have to be about
leveling the hacking skill and the
speech skill now with this it is of
course a lot of people have been
comparing this game to Fallout New Vegas
and
rightfully so I understand it's the same
company that had previously worked on
that game so of course you're going to
be seeing some few Aurelio some very
similar elements this being the
returning of perks and skills and stuff
that you can apply to your character to
be Fury's progress and hacking and
speech I find to be one of the most
important things at the moment in outer
worlds hacking in speech are excellent
choices instead of running around to
doing a lot more work than you need to
you can cut most of that effort in half
just by talking your way out of things
of course if you are you might actually
end up missing a few areas by you know
skipping part of a mission which of
course if you don't want to do that
that's entirely up to you I'm not gonna
tell you how to get to your character
but if you're really sick of doing the
constant back and forth doing jobs for
people when you just want to continue
with on with the main quest or something
of that sort or even talking your way
out of stuff that happened to do within
the main quest you can of course use the
speech skill at least in the early game
that's gonna require about 20 points in
each of the individual speech skills
which are pretty much all good and the
way that the speech skills work is that
every time you level up all you have to
do is put stuff into dialogue and that
will go all the way up to level 50 and
then once you at level 50 you want to
start putting in stuff individually into
those things like ally and persuasion
and all that type of stuff and more of
aggression just to totally fit the bill
and min/max your build and what exactly
you want to do for the character in this
playthrough for hacking it's pretty nice
because in the beginning because of what
we stated before about not being able to
sell weapons I wasn't actually able to
sell most of the stuff that I wanted and
that kind of hindered me later in the
game because I don't have enough money
to buy a few things later from other
vendors but because of the hacking skill
that allows you to actually get
suspended stock that you otherwise would
not get with inventing machines like
mods or other goodies that that vending
machine happens to sell and also give
you the ability to sell back your items
to a vending machine and other stuff
like that which you can normally not do
if you don't have a hacking skill number
three is gonna be about factions and I'm
not gonna go into specifics about each
faction you might just see their name
plastered on the right that has nothing
to do with anything of course there's no
spoilers that all these are just vendors
as you'll see but there are primary and
secondary factions within the game and
some have vendors who pledged to a
specific faction these can negatively
and positively affect your game if you
have a nice reputation with one group
they will give you what's called a
discount and you don't have to
as much but if they hate you then they
you will have to pay more because if
you're sure charge so definitely keep an
opera with vendors you like and whose
quest you're doing has to have the most
enjoyable experience and if you want to
see what reputation you are all you have
to do is go to the character selection
at the top click on reputation and it
will show your primary and secondary
factions and what they're like to
dislike of you is or you can actually
have them both like you and dislike you
at the exact same time according to the
in-game tips before has to be about fall
damage it's very apparent within the
first two minutes of the game that fall
damage is going to be a pain in the ass
since you are in space you jump quite a
lot higher than normal and fall damage
for this game is a lot crazier than in
other games that have this similar type
of RPG single-player feel to it in this
game you can take damage at some of the
smallest heights that I've ever seen so
definitely be careful on the distance
between you and the ground and
especially don't want to overshoot a
jump as you'll see here I was just
trying to run through the area get to my
quest accidentally jumped over this rock
that I didn't mean to fell to my death
basically instantly and yeah so it's
going even with the amount of health
that I had which wasn't really much the
time even though that that was a pretty
big height I still ended up dying and of
course you'll see as well I've been I
was taking damage from just these
smallest jumps even just good jumping
down a flight of stairs which you
normally don't take damage from like
other games like in Fallout New Vegas
and stuff so just be aware for that
number 5 is probably my most favorite
one and this is about listening to the
logs the dialogue and the terminals and
that seems fairly obvious of course this
is more of you have to whatever choice
you make is going to affect the end of
the game so it makes sense that you
would listen what I'm really talking
about terminals in this case other games
like of course everyone's been comparing
this game to fall it's I'm going to use
that as a reference again fallout had
terminals which usually just had
meaningless letters and notes some of
them actually did point you in the right
direction to maybe a unique item or
request but most of them was just more
for the lore in the story but the
biggest example of this game spin on it
is when you go to your ship for the
first time the unreliable and go
upstairs and visit a terminal that
Phineas is mentioned in in it states
that there is a shrink ray and Phineas
is lab and once you read that you can
actually fast travel it through space of
course to Phineas is lab which is
suspended in space and there you can
meet bub
and actually grab the shrink-ray very
early within the game and of course a
shrink-ray is pretty obvious of what it
does I don't need to explain to you what
that thing does and that same terminal
as well has also names of other unique
weapons that were listed on there as
well I have yet to get those I
completely forgot about those and tall's
making this video so I'm definitely
gonna have to go jump in and go grab
those but that's just what I wanted to
let you know so definitely keep an eye
out for that terminal and obviously this
isn't the only terminal that's going to
display every unique item but just
whenever you come across the terminal
that you might want to look into just
keep an eye out on what it might be
saying because then that might uh it
could also influence what choices you
make in the future for the story mode
just by learning a bit more information
yeah that's gonna be it for me guys let
me know what you guys think about this
game in the comments bowl I'm absolutely
loving outer worlds so so much there's
actually a genuinely one of my favorite
games so far in these past couple months
so yeah they as well thank you to
private division like I said before for
giving me an early code to let you know
about this stuff earlier I wanted to get
this out before everybody got a chance
to play so that they were hours or two
hours in like I was and then realizing
wow there's so much stuff that I had no
idea what to do so yeah guys hopefully
you did like the video if you did
definitely be sure to drop a like I'm
gonna be covering loads of outer world
stuff in the future we got some stuff
that'll be informative and also comedic
in the same sense more entertainment and
maybe yeah let me know how you guys
enjoyed the video be sure to drop a like
I'll definitely be uploading a lot more
outer world stuff in the future some
that are a bit more informative some
that are a bit more at the entertainment
value maybe some a bit of both but I
like them to be if you do enjoy guys
subscribe if you're new and take care
guys hope you enjoy outer worlds and
peace out